Okay. Okay. So, everybody, Prashant,
please come up here. Thank you very
much. So, closing remarks are going to
be pretty quick. Thank you for waiting
for me for 30 seconds.
Prashant, here we go.
So, just to update you a little bit
about what happened in the online
conference today. It's been insane.
We've had some some bugs, which is true,
but we've had almost 800 people
participating live. And as you guys went
for lunch and you are now going for our
party or reception here, there are
literally online events happening on
Zoom right this second with speakers and
just groups hanging together between
five and like 80 people in the room. So,
it's pretty cool what's going on over
there. My summary is very simple. I'm
really happy you're here and I'm happy
this is forming into a community. That
is my main thing. And now because it's
not me speaking anymore. Everybody
quiet. I want to give somebody else the
microphone. So give him the respect he
deserves. Salesforce has been amazing to
us. They refused to let us use their
logo to thank them in a more
sophisticated way. I would like to
quickly just say thank you to the people
who gave us so much of their time and
money for nearly nothing. uh Nostic, my
own company, Tact isle,
White Rabbit, Alion Futures and Alion
Adventures. Truly, if you see them,
shake their hands because they had no
reason to do this. We give them nothing
except for them to support the
community. And with that, thank you.
And with that, I want to over to
Prashant who manages all product
security at Salesforce. Not just to
thank him because I literally I I'm
really looking forward to the five
seconds I'm giving him up on stage to
hear what he has to say.
>> Absolutely. 5 seconds. I think I'm the
one who is standing behind uh good. I'm
the one who is standing between you and
I believe there is a happy hour or there
some reception going on right after
this. Okay. So first things first Gi
amazing zop amazing job getting the
community together. uh I know there have
been a change in the venue but I can
looking at the venue I can assure you
this is a much this is an upgrade for
sure. So um but then more importantly
the talks have been phenomenal. The the
sessions have been great. I think the
community is coming together. The the
problems that people are seeing in the
community of security and then the way
they're addressing it's all coming
together well. I will not take 5 minutes
or 5 seconds. I just want to say thank
you. Thank you GI. Thank you to the
entire community. Thank you to the
speakers and the volunteers and everyone
who got together to get this together
and make this happen. Um, thank you all.
We are Salesforce from Salesforce side.
We're happy to be a part of this
community and help this uh get it to
where it is today. Thank you again.
Enjoy and have fun. Thanks.